[Música]
una vez
algo que muchas personas se imaginan y
que me imagino que ustedes también se
deben estar preguntando ahorita
una pregunta muy frecuente que recibe
muchísimo es escribir
pero delante
cuando eso no podría estar más alejado
de la realidad sí es cierto que a veces
si un diseñador de modas desarrolla una
bonita amistad con una modelo es posible
que le regale ciertas prendas pero no es
precisamente que no vamos a bajar de la
pasarela con lo que teníamos puesto no
quisimos ver a la ropa el salto de una
colección anterior
una persona accionada con la carga de
publicitar emocionar mostrar o vender un
producto comercial generalmente de la
industria de la moda o de la industria
de la inversa
y precisamente el modelo se diferencia
de la danza porque no hay ningún tipo de
interpretación musical
no está poco que no estamos viviendo un
nuevo trago militar a tura ni mucho
menos entonces tomamos muchas de estas
artes escénicas se ubicarán salas y lo
aprecio por contratación pública
estoy haciendo en este momento frente a
ustedes ustedes envolviendo una verdad
no estoy como que leyendo en literaria
ni nada y tampoco estoy como bailando al
ritmo de alguna pieza musical de esa
manera en modelaje nuez es considerada
una forma artística pero si vemos una
sesión de platos típica que cuáles son
los elementos que la caracteriza
mi cámara un ciclorama de luces
maquillaje el peinado
qué más el diseño de la indumentaria que
estás usando y por supuesto la modelo y
si tenemos listas de elementos en común
que también se ven en la danza en el
teatro porque el modelaje es considerado
todavía con una frivolidad
el director creativo de chanel dice que
el secreto de modelaje no está perfecto
lo que uno necesita en su marca que las
personas puedan identificar en un
segundo
y no queda más que se están haciendo al
lograr esto
garantizar la venta del producto al
asociarlo a un rostro familiar vas a
comprar la carterita porque está la
dirija debo saber quién es entonces si
dijera que mentó suyo también
el siguiente punto es que una modelo no
necesariamente tiene que ser bella
como es pero típicamente bella es más si
tienen como algo particular que la ave
resalta del resto
esto es menor todavía por ejemplo veamos
del caso de cada vez le vi ni con sus
cejas demasiado pobladas que ésta
parecía un niño que más con sus ojos
como muy separados o la razón que tenía
un hueco entre los dientes y logró hacer
la campaña de ya que ya no hay ni york
estas particularidades como las
podríamos llamar defectos es una locura
llamarles defectos son lo que han
catapultado a la fama a estas chicas y
eso es lo que a mí me gusta
personalmente del modelaje que es un
vídeo de expresión que con mi cuerpo con
mi ser con mi existencia me convierto en
un medio artístico mediante el cual
fotógrafos diseñadores maquilladores
diseñadores de moda se pueden expresar
no todo está igual y dad
no soy yo eso es arte que alguien plasmó
sobre mí pero que sería de todo esto
bueno me caracteriza de tener formación
artística yo que me respalda la
licenciatura en animación digital que
obtuve me cuando estudié cuatro años en
costa rica y aunque no lo crean esas
paredes frías de aire acondicionado
cuando tratábamos cómo fueron la mejor
escuela de modelaje porque porque cuando
estamos diseñando personajes para
animación digital
por cierto si no les queda del todo
claro lo que es de animación digital
significa que yo hago pitching hitos que
éste le pidió a los chiquitos y cuando
estamos diseñando un chiquito para que
sea atractivo para que les guste a los
niños ya los grandes tenemos que tomar
en cuenta diferentes principios de la
animación ok
cuáles principios el más importante
desde la silueta solamente con ver un
personaje aunque esté todo rellenado en
negro solamente por el por su silueta no
podemos reconocer ustedes ven esto si no
puedes ir los nombres
pero ya saben cuáles son
la puesta en escena como interactúa el
personaje en el escenario en el mundo
que estás creando
la línea de acción este principio de la
animación favorito es una línea
imaginaria que se traza desde la cabeza
del personaje hasta la columna vertebral
y la última pierna de la acción
principal del cuerpo tener una línea de
acción bien definida ayuda a que el
personaje tenga claridad en sus
movimientos y que pueda expresar
claramente todo lo que queremos
comunicar si es agresivo si en su mismo
sin mucha anticipación la línea de
acción es el santo grial de la animación
pero qué tiene que ver la animación con
el modelaje ok
interesante imagino que ya no era el pj
me encanta analizarla porque incluyen
todo lo que acabo de decir ahí vemos del
el fondo es un cielo bastante plano ha
definido un solo tono y vemos que el
brazo yo yo yo soy estar acá vemos que
el brazo no está encima del cuerpo sino
que está donde sobre el fondo quedando
mejor silueta y la y la pelota de
voleibol también con su forma geométrica
corta y el dicho de que tengo el meñique
el avanzado también aporta silueta el
hecho de que tengo la pierna que está
más cerca de ustedes más acá de la
cámara perdón
hace que no te parezcan más largo de lo
que en realidad es por la ley de
perspectiva que estudies mientras
aprendí a dibujar el globo en el pecho
entonces claro quiero que se vea luego
roto mi cámara y mi pecho de la cámara
pero la cintura no hace no hace la
cámara sino lejos de ella para que
parezca más y que tengo más sin duda la
que en realidad tengo y estoy en
puntillas para aparecer mensaje y tengo
la cabeza para arriba para para que la
iluminación me favorezca y haga parecer
que estoy más tonificada de lo que en
realidad es historia
entonces el primer una de las primeras
tareas que yo tuve la clase de dibujo 2
y nos ponían a dibujar con reglas con
reglas la ex proyectan las luces y las
sombras para aprender a entender bien de
manera científica cómo funciona la luz y
la sombra es wanda que escapan y más
adelante pueden aplicar esos principios
con
con ilustraciones más avanzadas como
esta ilustración de la clase de
ilustración conceptual que ya al final
de la carrera pero luego también cuando
te gradúas sin también tener ganas de
seguir siendo modelo puede seguir
aplicando estos principios de
iluminación sabiendo que por ejemplo si
tenemos una iluminación bien dura te va
a parecer ver tonificada y fuerte
entonces tenés que poner la cara de
cierta manera de ames de luz que tengo
aquí si hago esto
si hace unos círculos oscuros debajo de
mi cara pero si hago esto entonces da
como pueda expresar fuerza
en cambio si tengo una iluminación bien
suave que lo que expresa ternura y
delicadeza joyería etcétera lo que a lo
que quiero llegar es que solamente
porque nos desempeñamos en una cosa no
significa que no podamos hacer bien
otras cosas todo lo contrario una
actividad que te genere conocimiento
lo ideal es poder aplicar este
conocimiento en otras actividades en una
actividad que pueda que a primera vista
parezca totalmente opuesta vean nada más
como coloco las manos en la cátedra y
vean cómo el personaje coloca las manos
en el arpa y dígame si no ven una
conexión y digamos si no ven más que una
frivolidad
al fin y al cabo nosotros somos más que
la suma de nuestras partes pero depende
de cada uno de nosotros trazar es la
conexión entre estas actividades es
quien nos enriquece como voy a hacer que
esto me sirva para esto otro
como no voy a fortalecer mi conocimiento
depende de cada uno de nosotros hacer
trazar esas líneas y ver qué hacemos con
nuestras carreras con nuestras vidas y
con nuestras futuras muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]